améliorer le service pour qu'il
y ait encore moins de voiture?
Si vous vous déplacez
à Montréal, vous savez combien
♪ ♪ ♪
MÉLANIE LANGLAIS, cycliste
- Si c'était juste  de moi,
je serais juste en vélo.
De un, avec les enfants, c'est
pas possible encore. J'aimerais
ça pouvoir un jour le faire,
mais leur école est à
25 minutes quasiment en auto.
Vous allez voir la run qu'on
fait tous les matins.
- Les jours se suivent et ne se
ressemblent pas pour l'actrice
et coach de yoga.
Mélanie  se déplace à pied,
à vélo, en métro ou en voiture,
selon l'horaire de chacun et
le moyen le plus efficace.
Pour reconduire les enfants
à l'école, c'est la voiture.
- Chaussures et manteau et
veste, Monsieur!
Les dernières minutes sont
toujours à la course. On y va!
- Josh et Noah sont en garde
partagée. Une semaine sur deux,
ils vivent chez leur père et
Mélanie, leur belle-mère, près
du Vieux-Port. Mais ils vont à
l'école dans le quartier de leur
mère, Rosemont.
- On y va!
- S'y rendre en transport en
commun prendrait 90 minutes,
aller-retour, soir et matin.
Il faudrait marcher 15 minutes
jusqu'au métro Beaudry.
Il faudrait prendre le métro
jusqu'à Pie IX. Là, prendre
l'autobus pour monter Saint-
Michel puis descendre au coin de
Saint-Joseph. Il faudrait qu'on
se tape toute cette "run" là.
Notre-Dame, le matin,
Notre-Dame, le matin.
Il y a du monde là.
- Quand Mélanie est au volant,
ce qui l'agace le plus, c'est
l'attitude des automobilistes
agressifs et les nombreux
chantiers.
- Ça passait ici, avant.
Là, ça ne passe plus.
CATHERINE MORENCY, professeure
titulaire, Polytechnique Mtl
- Quand j'entends : "Ah, les
chantiers, puis il y a encore de
la congestion!" Mais il va
toujours y en avoir. Ça se peut
juste pas qu'il n'y ait pas de
congestion.
- Pourquoi?
- Bien parce qu'il y a trop de
véhicules, ça ne rentre pas.
- Pour Catherine Morency,
sommité mondiale en génie des
transports, la bataille contre
la congestion automobile doit
être menée sur deux fronts :
mieux aménager les routes pour
favoriser la marche, le vélo
et le transport collectif.
Deux : réduire notre attachement
viscéral aux voitures.
- J'ai une fixation :
il faut affranchir les gens
de la nécessité de posséder
un ou plusieurs véhicules pour
se déplacer.
- C'est que le nombre de
véhicules sur les routes
augmente plus rapidement que
la démographie. L'an dernier,
malgré le confinement,
105 000 voitures de plus ont été
immatriculées au Québec,
la moitié à Montréal.
Les nouvelles routes,
les nouveaux développements,
sont encore souvent aménagés
sans trop penser aux piétons
et aux cyclistes.
« Qu'est-ce qu'il fait lui? »
- Après avoir ramené la voiture
chez elle, Mélanie se rend
à vélo au gymnase, où elle donne
un cours de yoga.
- 17 minutes en vélo, mais 6
minutes en auto puis 25 minutes
à virailler pour me trouver du
parking, ça fait que des fois,
c'est mieux d'y aller en "bike".
Tout ce qui est aménagement
pour les modes actifs, donc la
marche et le vélo, c'est urgent.
Il y a des rues, là, c'est
épouvantable! C'est extrêmement
dangereux.
- C'est jusqu'ici, à cette
lumière-là, que j'ai vraiment
failli mourir! Juste là.
- On fait la promotion de
l'acquisition de véhicules, oui,
électriques, mais en même temps,
ça reste de l'automobile privée.
Il n'y a pas vraiment
d'incitatifs pour décider de se
déplacer à pied, décider de se
déplacer à vélo.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Deuxième journée avec Mélanie.
Ce jour-là elle se déplace
à pied et en métro dans divers
quartiers de la ville pour
rencontrer des clients.
- C'est moi qui ai gagné
le tirage de la carte OPUS
aujourd'hui. Pour que je ne
prenne plus la voiture, il
faudrait vraiment qu'il y ait
un meilleur système d'autobus
autour de chez nous aussi,
qui nous amènerait dans d'autres
directions que celles que le métro fait déjà,
qui est déjà très efficace.
- Je pense qu'on n'a pas assez
aimé nos réseaux de transports
en commun ou on n'a pas compris
l'effet. Là, il faut s'imaginer
des territoires comme Montréal
sans métro. Ça ne marche pas,
c'est l'apocalypse. Le métro
ferme au complet, c'est
l'apocalypse à Montréal.
- Pour la spécialiste de
la mobilité, il faut encourager
financièrement les
automobilistes à adopter
d'autres modes de transport.
Et les villes doivent rendre
les modes alternatifs plus efficaces et attrayants.
Les usagers du transport en
commun sont aussi, forcément,
des piétons.
- Il y a certains endroits
où ça va quand même plus vite
de marcher pour me rendre que
d'essayer d'y aller en transport
en commun.
- C'est  à pied et à vélo que
Mélanie vit ses plus grandes frustrations, car les rues
de Montréal sont encore, à bien des
endroits, des courses à
obstacles.
- Je vais devenir intense, là,
parce que ça me prend au coeur,
cette affaire-là.
- Il y a encore beaucoup
de rues sans trottoirs et
des intersections dangereuses
à traverser.
- Là, regardez, si je veux
traverser pour m'en aller tout
droit vers chez nous, je peux
pas. Je pourrais pas, jamais!
À aucun moment je ne vais
pouvoir traverser.
La lumière est verte, ça flash,
elle va "flasher" jaune.
Regardez la flèche, elle vire
jaune. Ça fait que là, notre
solution, ça serait de traverser de l'autre bord.
- Mélanie ne comprend pas que la
ville encourage la construction
effrénée de condos dans des quartiers
comme le Vieux-Montréal et le centre-ville,
qui sont déjà saturés au niveau
routier et qui manquent de
pistes cyclables.
- Quand on regarde des aménagements
avec une rue quatre voix de
large avec des mini-trottoirs,
pas d'aménagement pour les
vélos, c'est de la
discrimination. Il faut vraiment
faire un diagnostic des façons
d'améliorer les conditions
de marche et de déplacement à vélo. Enfants, personnes
âgées inclus, personnes avec
limitations incluses.
Donc il faut vraiment considérer
l'ensemble des voyageurs.
- Ça me prend au coeur parce que, tu sais, c'est des vies
humaines au final. La réalité,
c'est que moi, si je me fais
frapper par un char, je meurs.
C'est super, la gang!